et
un joli qu'est-ce que tu ferais si je te
quittais
d'acheter
Catherine Ringer si je te dis tu penses
à quoi tu me réponds quoi
[Musique]
je pense à ma coupe de douche je crois
je sais anglaise là dessus
Catherine
[Musique]
je pense
beaucoup plus que moi
c'est pas chiant de travailler toujours
avec la même personne c'est-à-dire
d'être tout le temps avec en studio sur
scène partout
[Musique]
Catherine Angers
[Rires]
[Musique]
des fois c'est terriblement triste et
puis des fois on s'amuse comme des
petits fous c'est vrai
[Musique]
et moi qu'est-ce que je fais à ton avis
est-ce que tu m'aimes
[Musique]
fais-moi un sourire alors
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu